yeah hello welcome to this video palm
burrito okay okay i recently got the new
Victor Borge on book he always wants to
go Bishop c5 here in this kind of line
that wasn't really aware that this is
some-something frequently played but it
definitely looks okay only 95 here okay
wow isn't that just completely fine for
black
his real bishop doesn't look very great
food doesn't look great on a 40 came and
I have some very clear ideas him wow
that looks pretty ugly f2e for something
like g3 should be really bad now Queen
83 Bishop g4 okay so let's see
just the normal move or can I do
something drastic hear stuff like rook
f3 or Bishop h3 is very close very close
maybe this one for Bishop f3 yeah this
is at least probably preventing quick
checkmates should have three tags that's
not working and to look f3 it's not it's
not threatening that much okay so just
just no much stuff then check go for a
good end game even though it feels like
there should have been more
you cannot take f8 and to see 7s Queenie
one is made but DK he can take that huh
didn't think about that at all check
check I can probably go King you on
check dad come on three plane re badly
now at the moment j i can only be glad
that he's playing even worse so I'm
again in good shape yeah I think let's
see can I get get that pawn directly on
Bishop c4 is also possible should be
three yeah okay
and that position out of the opening
really was excellent and this is not not
really am a good result hey specialty
cook he's got Bishop d7 now technically
covering this but now I can double a
check those two pawns and s got Bishop
see aid but at the end I should probably
have enough player or not I don't see
white winning this but it shouldn't be
like that it should be like why just
losing out of the opening so can I do
this or is that risky bra on hand Jim he
offered me a draw
now there is no way to run around really
no way to try to do something with black
yeah at the opening result oh my god
yeah I mean this is just fantastic just
fantastic for black and it should be
some kind of straight win so what is the
straight win Luke f6 is the win okay and
then there must be something this is
just just totally awful with those
pieces here and black being come having
everything activated something like here
let's bishop age 3 m 4 root g6 ok hmm
you know this is flat-out winning me
minus 3 i played this then didn't want
to again like spend like two minutes
trying to refute this stuff and then
lose on time but this is giving away
most of my advantage I wasn't even
thinking about briefly thinking about
stuff like that which is pretty close to
working it's a draw funny enough it's
given the engine gives draw which shows
how how bad White's position is and this
is probably also move I get this is this
is a good defense taking I don't know
and that ok that's it doesn't matter we
have six wins so this is the problem
yeah now I actually overlooked that c7
was hanging I mean in that way chance is
why I just went for the trades I can
still go here with a pretty clear
advantage as he 3s attacked Queen d2
Bishop f3 and black is clearly better
check yeah I simply blundered that porn
check check check the only good thing is
that it still probably quite ok yeah
yeah the engine is on equal equal all
the time here of course I cannot take
because of f6 it's a neat little trick
Bishop c4 guarantee he offered the draw
which is realistic there's nothing to do
he's always tied to that porn and
there's no way no way forward yeah shame
at that Luke f6 move should have won the
game okay thanks for watching